primeira viagem que eu fiz eu fiz para
São Paulo e comecei a viajar para mais
para para fora do Nordeste né coms shows
e uma coisa que eu percebi o pessoal de
fora do Nordeste ele tem um preconceito
com a gente e o é isso por quê
Porque eles pensam que lá que aqui no
Nordeste só tem sol e calor é só sol e
calor se tu é de ondee eu sou do Piauí a
pessoa Ave Maria meu Deus do céu tá
doido parece que eu trouxe o sal no
bolso para jogar nele eu não entendo
Mano eu não posso sentir calor em São
Paulo não cara não posso se eu fizer
assim o cara que foi se eu estou com
calor ai tu sente calor Tu não é do
Nordeste não eu digo eu sou do Nordeste
eu não sou fio do Satanás não pá o povo
não é É sério
cara tem que ser sofrido eles não
acreditam que é do Piauí cara tem que
ser queimado de sol sofrido de buscar
água meio-dia com balde na
cabeça meus oito irmãos desnutrido